Sam we need to explain these research
groups before we do anything else really
don't we let the ERG for instance they
would have become pretty familiar to
some people over the years but what
exactly are they
so they're a little curiosity Kimberly
that that Nestles in a sort of
underexamined part of our political
system
um and this is where
um under a quirk that's grown up over
decades
um you could have bands groups of MPS
from the same party all getting together
and what they do is they as it were
subscribed to a bit of a club uh and as
you say there's a European research
group that's a club on brexit there's a
northern research Group which is a club
for Tory MPS on leveling up there's a
socialist campaign Group which is a kind
of fans of Jeremy corbyn really uh uh
for members of the uh for the labor
party what they do is that they can
divert a little bit of their office
allowance a couple of thousand pounds a
year uh maybe a little bit more of their
of the money that goes to fund their
office to a kind of uh what's known as a
research group to prepare briefings and
um basically help them come up with
common positions so for instance the
European research group for for many
years now has been
doing research about how to get the kind
of uh the kind of brexit that would mean
the cleanest break with the European
Union and pushing for that that meant
leaving the single Market leaving the
Customs Union uh the northern research
Group which began in 2021 under uh Jake
Berry that has been pushing uh stuff to
do with um leveling up and advancing the
agenda of some of those Northern MPS
those red wall MPS that you saw uh
elected when Boris Johnson won the 2019
general election but here's the thing
Kimberly he's one of the reasons why why
it's quite interesting which is what
these groups end up doing is it they get
some public money uh in order to do
research but the groups more often than
not end up kind of fronting squabbles
with the leadership whether it's the ERG
that famously kind of was a key part of
the defenestration of Theresa May uh or
the northern research Group which um
calls um which has caused uh trouble for
consecutive Prime Ministers and uh one
of the things we've done is produced the
first ever leaderboard of the amounts of
money that go into these groups in order
uh essentially to to to support them um
NH party has one but but then you've got
the northern research group that's in
this Parliament we've got 139 000 pounds
of public money the European research
group that's just got under are just
under a hundred thousand socialist
campaign groups sixty seven thousand and
a a Tory writer Center group called The
Common Sense Group which is about six
thousand pounds uh of public money and
it's just a little under
scrutinized corner of um of of politics
but nevertheless enormously influential
I just think quite a lot of people a lot
of listeners a lot of viewers would be
surprised that actually it falls to them
to the taxpayer to support their work
given kind of what they what they spend
quite a lot of time doing
and the investigation focuses on the NRG
you mentioned them the northern research
group so tell us about your
investigation and how that plays into it
so we were looking at all of these
groups but but we raised one eyebrow at
uh what was going on in the in the
northern research group this all started
because we in the last set of
Westminster accounts um discovered that
people in the northern research group
got donations they got donations from a
northern broad Bank company so mid small
to mid-sized Northern Broadband company
called IX Wireless and basically if
you're in the energy you sort of got
this donation of you know a few thousand
pounds and uh if you remember back to
January people who uh who saw
Westminster accounts won back then uh
you'll have seen me trying to sort of
trying to find out why this company was
giving money
um they didn't tell us at the time uh so
I went and knocked on their door but and
it was just an empty office block it was
all flooded now subsequently i x was
engaged with us and they said that they
gave money to members of the northern
research group in order to support the
northern agenda to support the leveling
upper gender and they thought this was a
good way uh backing the people in this
group is a good way uh of doing that but
after doing Westminster account one I
was until I buy a couple of Tory MPS
they're a bit nervous about joining up
the northern research group because
there was this conundrum involving
public money uh money from you know
their office allowance and these
donations and and I didn't really
understand what they were talking about
so we got some of Sky's data people to
to look into it
and we discovered what what could well
be something of a pattern which is
particularly in 2021 when the NRG was
starting up it it looked or in several
cases it is the it's the case that you
have MPS signing up to the northern
research group actively telling uh the
ipsa the um the organization that
oversees MPS allowances and expenses to
to authorize payments of two and a half
thousand pounds to to the NRG uh of that
kind of public money allowance and then
two or three weeks later or in some
cases two or three days later that MP
would get two and a half thousand pounds
as a donation from IX Wireless and and
there was just a you know striking
correlation between some of the money
that was being authorized to go from you
know the public person to the NRG with
with the kind of amounts that were
coming uh from from IX Wireless and
um I went and talked to uh some of the
MPS something said oh coincidence no
link at all but one of them said look we
knew we knew you that if we signed on
the dotted line and joined the NRG then
we would get a donation now the question
there is is does that you know would
they have signed up to the NRG if they
weren't getting a donation is is it
there for a proper use of public money
all of these questions being raised but
are now going to be looked at uh by ipsa
that as a result of looking at the data
that underpins uh this investigation and
decided to open what they call a review
it's basically an investigation into
into what was going on there now we've
talked to uh Jake Berry the chairman uh
we've got a little bit of video
hopefully you'll be able to watch some
of that video on this podcast of Jake
Berry absolutely denying that there is
any link between the donations and the
public money but as I say I I've talked
to you know eight or MPS remember the
northern research group we say well you
know I knew there was a donation coming
that's why I signed up to it so now
there is an investigation announced
today by ipsa who gonna look into this
and you know we will see uh we will see
what they come up with but it's a it's
interesting because I think the whole
question of public money this in in this
area is as I say not not one that people
have looked at particularly closely
before